dans le droit on a introduit au début
des années 2000 la notion de sujétion
psychologique donc ça existe simplement
c'est dans l'abus dans l'article 223 du
15 2 du code pénal
simplement en fait cette notion de
sujétion psychologique qui était celle
en fait de manipulations mentales ou
d'emprise elle est extrêmement difficile
à appliquer pour les juges parce que il
faut trouver des critères pour la
déterminer or c'est extrêmement
compliqué de d'appliquer ou de
déterminer ce qui est une solution c'est
psychologique c'est pour ça qu'on fait
les juges préfèrent utiliser par exemple
l'escroquerie qui est plus facile à
caractériser donc le droit a été
psychologie c'est vous avez tout à fait
raison
vous connaissez bien cette question avec
l'idée de placer au centre la question
du consentement donc effectivement les
sujets sont sont liées sur ce qui est de
la manipulation mentale elle même et je
crois que l'intervention au début de de
la delà de la représentante de
l'association des des proches ou des
victimes de sectes
l'aladi c'est à dire qu'est ce que ce
qu'est ce qu'on comptait ce qu'on dit
qu'une personne est manipulée or en fait
on le dit en général ou bien après coup
ou bien ce sont des proches qui le
disent il faut désigner en fait des
changements de la vie quotidienne delà
de la personne elle se comporte plus de
la même manière il faut trouver
quelqu'un en fait à qui on attribue ces
changements et donc c'est comme ça que
ça se comme ça que ça se se caractérise
mais évidemment la personne quant à elle
la décide en fait d'en faire un choix de
vie qui est le sien même si c'est un
choix de vie minoritaire elle à dire
mais non je ne suis pas manipulée
simplement j'ai choisi une ville
différente qui n'est plus à la vie en
fait et qui ce qui est celle et après
les gens peuvent changer
on n'a pas beaucoup parlé en fait on a
des sorties de sac
il ya des gens qui passent en fait il
faut voir que c'est des milieux qui
peuvent être très composite
vous pouvez à la fois être dans un
groupe il restait deux ans ne pas être
complètement impliqué dedans sortir vous
intéresser à des thérapies alternatives
etc
et c'est tout ça en fait cet univers là
en fait dont on
dont on parle
[Musique]